hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's a new week in fortnight and
although they've moved to a two-week
update cycle loads of things have been
discovered this week if you're new
around these parts this is the series in
which we search for map changes and
secrets and slowly pieced together
storylines and try to predict the future
slap code atom arrow in the star to
support these shenanigans and let's do
this you know what I'm starting oh no
this can't be her watch is burning down
before I had a chance to live now don't
worry this place is completely fine the
new item for the week allows us to burn
structures in-game the fireflies can be
gathered anywhere on the island right
now and gets us one step closer to the
return of the greatest LTM ever the
floor is lava this has to be the season
to bring it back right pretty please
epic okay back to the real stuff
[Music]
so the Marauders what do you think about
these guys they arrive from outer space
and Crashdown ready to shoot and party
some legitimately have aim bot and some
are so dumb they could be related to me
each of the Marauders is a different
class including this thick boy well get
this have you ever moved the camera
close enough to their faces each one has
a face to discover whoa okay not all of
them but most of them have a face to
discover do you recognize any of these
people well these guys are from the save
the world portion of the game these are
the heroes of that fortnight game mode
the shot guys here Sara can be found two
and a few others but this thick boy I'm
paying extra attention to because this
guy is Kyle a constructor class in save
the world I'm so happy to see him make
the jump to be our but there's another
constructor who is more important than
Kyle if you've been run here before I'm
sure you know who that is penny where
the heck is penny penny
this has to be deliberate right to have
so many saved the world characters out
here in force only to leave out the one
which matters the most epic why you
bully us there are many pennies to
choose from I only want one of them I
realize I go on about this far too often
so let me know in the comments if I
should shut up about penny I can take it
but if you're with me hit me with team
thick in the comments let's see how many
of us there are
okay I've started ranting I'll get back
on point if the Marauders can't find
anyone they'll have a dance party to
regain health I like that touch they
also have their own builds which have
this white line across so you can
identify and track them down if you want
their loot one day the old day will
start cranking 90's and only penny can
stop this come on penny
let's go back to the story of gnomes and
bears last week my search for the
misfits was fruitless but thanks to so
many of you guys I now know where to
find them and we've uncovered something
very interesting if you didn't know
after the number truce last season the
two sides have now set up a surrender
zone under a white flag these guys are
the best of friends playing games and
enjoying a drink together Gandalf and
Nick furry the super chilled but wait a
minute
those two using the telescope maybe
giving us a clue here by following the
general direction of the scope it leads
all the way back to gray him in his
ivory tower this shows that this genome
is going to be part of something new so
let's break down the evidence well
there's only one piece of evidence so
far but let's break that one thing down
the pirate flag it's highly likely this
is only for a challenge but then I got
word of an imposter pirate near the huge
whirlpool look for yourself in the Attic
of this building is something strange
another misfit bear looking mighty
similar to Nick furry by the way I don't
name these characters when we find
someone new you guys name it anyway this
guy is in full pirate mode with a
high-tech galleon built for the high
seas or it's a bathtub he can dream I
suppose but the real question here is
the loot beside him oh gee pirate gold
from chapter 1 what could this mean it
can't be a coincidence that the pirate
flag is found at the Radio Shack and
only a few days later pirate's gold was
found we need more clues to solve this
oh hang on
does this mean I can bring back my bud
pirate dad jokes I really like pirate
jokes I'm completely hooked sorry not
sorry
Oh before I move on a few people have
asked to confirm that I have seen the
bear gnome show going on at a no sweat
storage building I sure have thank you
for the heads up and I also checked on
the gnome guarding the sacred golden
toilet in the underwater damn what a
trooper I guess this guy lives here now
gnome sweet gnome that was a bad joke
I need help with gnome jokes please I
will legit be in the comments throwing
carts out for bad
jokes I can use in future episodes
thanks in advance ok let's move on to
something else something potentially
mind-blowing and story-related did you
see how the season was revealed with
Midas a beaten man on a raft
well moments before the shark attacked
look in the background and you'll see a
desert island you'll likely think Adam
that means nothing but look again it has
three trees and some sort of sign on the
right do you recognize it well one year
ago to this very week fortnight's
shoulders a comedy shot in which Jonesy
is marooned on a desert island and he
uses a flare gun to call for help things
didn't go well for him and just as he
picks up the Vic Rowe take a look at the
island three trees and a signpost the
very same one as the season 3 reveal
there's exactly one year in between
these two videos could this be
coincidence yeah it could be could this
be a reused assets yeah definitely
or could this link to the storyline were
epic foreshadowing the future like
they've done so many times before or are
they showing us that this narrative we
are following is being told out of order
I'll need to go away and make a story
video to explain what I mean there but
at face value the same island in the
background has to mean something I just
wish I could find it in game it reminds
me of the carving tree last season I'm
still looking for that right now on a
side note if this theory is correct we
already have an origin story to explain
pili agent Jonesy couldn't leave things
well enough alone alright I think I'm
going too far reel me back in
[Music]
so I went to visit the crustaceans that
lived on the island which is now a huge
whirlpool sad to say they've lost their
home but in the replay files these guys
are still here
vibing under the waves some have moved
on though and created a new home south
of steamy stacks on an island made of
trash it's a tough time for them but
they're still in high spirits the thing
many of us missed on day one is the
shape of this island do you see it it's
shaped like a piranha fish hiding in
plain sight at first I thought this was
a flopper but look at those teeth
this thing is vicious again is this
foreshadowing something or just a cool
little easter egg I continued looking
for clues around the map and noticed
something at the authority whilst moving
the camera across the table check out
the reflection this is the original
agency complete with the ego logos and
the og table and even Midas's golden
chair I'm sure this isn't a hint or a
clue or something like that it's just
simply someone didn't switch out the
textures but I like it still awesome all
the same to see this and it reminds us
of simpler times when shark attacks and
Marauders weren't our main issues for
survival whilst I was looking around the
island my camera clipped underneath the
world so I quickly checked many
locations to see if anything was hiding
for example I went to the bunker and
nope nothing is behind those doors just
yet I also checked under the authority
to see if I could find the doomsday
device and no there's nothing the only
thing of real note here is this a small
piece of rectangular grass which wasn't
here last time I checked these things
are usually placeholders or items which
contain future code variables pretty
cool to see in-game though in fact there
were more things to note under the waves
the vending machines are still present
around the island and remember the
original ego plane which crashed on the
island all those months ago it's still
here but it's now updated to confirm the
water level is dropping the island is
degrading and now a wing is hanging over
the edge by clipping through the wall
below we can see the planes other
propeller buried into the ground this
all tells us that the
two levels will be declining and soon we
will see a new world filled with decay
and destruction happy days above the
water we should note that the pizza pit
truck isn't waiting around
it's relocating currently using a
tugboat to find a new home where do you
think this thing could stop the other
fast-food vans are on land already I'm
pretty safe right now could this be the
return of the food fight
get your butt up with two sweaty sands
and you'll see a building crew has moved
in to expand or change this place around
but here's something to note it looks
like a movie is being shot on the pier
maybe it's Aquaman or maybe this season
is following the chapter one arc and the
movie set which was interrupted by
meteor showers do you remember that that
storyline was great and right now we
have an astronaut with a meteor in the
battle pass so things certainly line up
okay so there we have it
week two in the books what did I miss
and how do you think the story will
evolve the water levels are set to drop
later this week so I'll be back again
once that happens to give you another
update on screen now ask some of the
people who used code a damaru to grabbed
the battle past this season and over
1,000 people used my code which blows my
mind but all that money is going
straight back to you guys in giveaways
I'll explain more when I can anyway
please know that I have so many more
people to thank in my Twitter DMS before
I name them here in the video so sorry
for the wait I've never had support like
this before and I will reply to every
legitimate code and Amaro DM you sent
it'll just take me time to get there but
I will get there thank you once again
for sticking around I really appreciate
it you're awesome
stay that way I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]